here's the thing
without these costumes and the
helicopter
would have been sloppy joe awful yeah
[Music]
just watch lele for a second
look at her little face like she's just
leaving face is really really cute i
feel a little disappointed that we got
it's very much so loose
tayden
it's a bit of a mess
brooklyn
kenley
and bella
are your three really strong people yeah
i'm just sad because now someone will go
home
i just hope it won't be me i thought
emily was too but
i just love her
emily messed up the terms why do you
love her she had the most obvious mess
up
she is like having trouble with the
pressure
kaia surprised me kyle was good dallas
does really good sometimes i feel like
dallas is just like there
i think we could have done better
and i feel like jojo and jess are upset
and disappointed
her and tiny tea blended in some of the
choreography but they weren't 100 in the
choreography that's not the best like
the core group of kids right so did leah
she blended she should have popped on
stage she didn't pop we put her in blue
with a red hair she should have popped
it
all right let's go check it out let's go
see him when they set forth i was like
scared to look behind me like of her
reaction i was like oh my gosh oh my
gosh
[Music]
we got fourth
i'm very happy that we got fourth
you beat over half the kids
could we do better absolutely absolutely
if some mistakes were not made
you definitely could have won
i'm looking forward to next week i think
i could be tougher
i think some of you
are really going to struggle if you stay
[Music]
you